how do leaders maintain optimism when
they are tired if you've ever been in a
position of leadership you know that
leadership can be extremely lonely
sometimes it's hard to relate to folks
on your team and you definitely can't
just come to work or show up on your
team and just start crying and venting
it just won't work and so it can be kind
of isolating so one of the most
important things any effective leader
has to do is maintain their close
friendships you have to have people that
you can go to to vent to cry to let it
all out where it's a safe environment
where you're not giving instructions or
telling people this is the end of the
organization but rather you just need to
get it all out of you have those
cathartic experiences in fact I take it
super seriously I have a rule with my
friends that there's no crying alone and
so if any one of us is ever completely
overwhelmed we call each other and say
do you have a minute I just need to vent
or I just need to cry or I just need to
get this out and amazingly that gets us
right back on the path